Jorge Ramos also works as an anchor at
Univision which unlike RT has not been
forced to register as a foreign agent he
also wrote the book stranger the
challenge of Latino immigrant in the
Trump era we spoke with him just a
minute ago
Jorge thanks for joining us
I appreciate great to be here thank you
so the first and maybe most important
question is why should we let these
asylum seekers these migrants into our
country I think the United States is
becoming a hostile even dangerous
country for Refugees and for immigrants
nothing we have a long tradition of
being generous of accepting other
immigrants from countries where they're
fleeing violence and poverty and lack of
democracy I think that's precisely what
the United States is and at the end
talker I think it's simply a matter of
deciding what kind of country we want to
be and it seems at this point that we
are talking about only a few hundred
refugees and put it in context from the
65 million refugees that are in the
world the United States except they're
only 84,000 in 2016 and with president
Romney's gonna be even less so it's
simply a matter of deciding what country
do we want to be well we've accepted
about 13 million refugees economic
refugees who are in our country now
illegally but back up for one second you
said that this is a hostile dangerous
place for refugees then why would you
want them to come here if the United
States is so dangerous well I mean
that's much much better than if you're a
father in Tegucigalpa san pedro sula and
you have a son and that's on it wants to
be recruited by the by the gangs or if
they threatened your only daughter they
want to rape her what will you do I mean
maybe the only option for them is to
come to the United States oh but it's
not
I understand look I love this country I
was born here I'm not a citizen of any
other country obviously I'm for America
and I plan to stay so you don't need to
convince me why people would want to
come I understand why they would accept
but in order to get here they passed
through Mexico which is by many measures
of rich countries at the 15th largest
economy in the world there are 30
Mexican billionaires got a bigger
economy than Saudi Arabia they're
sleeping on this
Tawana why doesn't the Mexican
government help them well its first of
all they don't want to stay in Mexico
they want to come to the United States
and second of all if you're fleeing
violence if you feel dancing in Honduras
or in Salvador or Guatemala why would
you want to go to Mexico when in the
last five years more than a hundred
thousand people were killed by drug
violence would you would you stay in
Mexico of course not it doesn't make
absolutely no I mean they want to come
to violence wanna fly business class to
Zurich and move to the Alps but you know
I don't get to because it's not my
country so that's what you want to do
you want to close to the United States
yes I want to revert to what we were
which is a country of laws where people
can come here but they do so legally we
have over a million people come here
every year legally they fill out the
paperwork they get in line from around
the world and I don't know why that
system doesn't work they want to come
here legally they want to come here
legally they're waiting in Tijuana is
just that for two days they haven't been
allowed even to talk to an agent there
are they're they're trying to come here
and claim asylum which in effect means a
court date will be set and the
overwhelming majority will not show up
for court and they will blend in with
the other true I mean they're fleeing
violence they're being they're playing
dance to them because we have reporters
talking to them because we know who they
are we talking every single day with
them we've been following them for 25
days that's why we know who they are
that's why we know that they're not
preeminence and terrorists and they're
not rapists that's that's why we know
who they are the one who was a member of
ms-13 who was caught last week who
admitted he was a member of ms-13 What
did he say when you talked to him well I
haven't talked to him and again oh you
didn't want to prove analyze the whole
group simply
that's not good right Mexican citizen
lecturing me about what kind of country
America is I love that but let me ask
you this one of them said he was from
ms-13 that was his description of his
own affiliation
you're saying I'm criminalizing him by
repeating what he said about himself
so maybe what you're really engaging in
is propaganda not fact-finding no no
what I'm saying is that if you want to
criminalize the whole Caravan which is
not composed by baton regimens you know
there is no invasion if you want to
criminalize the hundreds of them oh
there's an invasion here legally I think
that's an invade look if 13 million
illegals showed up in Mexico tomorrow
and wouldn't leave and if people from
other countries like you called anyone
who wanted to make them leave a racist I
think you would call it what it is which
is an invasion what is the thing is that
if they're fleeing if they're asking for
political asylum we have to listen to
them and on the other hand why don't
well because that's the long tradition
that we've had just to accept and
protect those who are vulnerable those
who are being paid hold on why is it
America's unique obligation to take in I
mean there are 1.2 billion people in
Africa all of them have lower standards
of living than Americans many of them
are living in violent places do they all
have a right to come here it's a real
question do they could it could it be
because we are the most powerful and the
richest country in the world which
doesn't believe in diversity or
immigration just so you know do they
have any obligation because they're in
our hemisphere and we're also
responsible for that I mean they're
fleeing violence right so why do you
think they're fleeing and these drug
wars in Central America and Mexico are
happening just just because it's a it's
a TV project know it's happening simply
because they're more than 25 million
Americans who use illegal drugs and
we're also responsible well
the junkies so Mexico sends in your
heroin yes it does Mexico is now the
largest manufacturer of crystal meth we
used to make it ourselves now they make
it they kill tens of thousands of Rabbis
every year those families we're also
supposed to work for that violence oh
we're responsible for heroin addiction
so someone who's who's taking heroin
he's responsible the junkie living on
the street is responsible for these
people being here is that what you're
saying no what I'm saying is that when
you have about 25 million US citizens
who use illegal drugs it has
consequences in the whole hemisphere
drugs are coming from his max along in
Central America and Mexico and the
violence that's happening in those
places it's also published partly
responsible for the consumers in this
country 60,000 people died of drug
Odie's last year most of those drugs
came from Mexico but it's our faults and
not only do we have to drop our borders
ignore our own laws take any poor person
around the world who wants to come here
but we have to it because we're a moral
because we're dying of drug ADIZ that's
so you think that the US and US
consumers have absolutely no
responsibility for the drug wars in
Mexico in Colombia in Peru and Central
America they're completely linked
absolutely they're completely linked and
guess what not only that how about the
guns and the rifles being used by
responsibility and we are in the United
States we have responsibility for the
things that are happening you voted the
Mexican presidential election I just
find it amazing that you can demand you
a citizen it's a Mexican election so
I've been voting the Mexican election
right now for in the US election and now
it's confusing for you but that's does
that's what happens and there are
millions of people around the world with
dual citizenship I'm just one of them
yeah well I'm opposed to it yeah if I
can say that for most reasons but it's
just funny how we have a moral
obligation because we're bad renewable
to subsidize the reservoirs we're the
richest and the most powerful country in
the world
people want to come here and we're an
example of democracy and generosity I
think that's that's right idea forgiving
the victim where a was great to see you
thank you